[Musique]
malgré les efforts entrepris au cours de
ces dernières années il reste encore
dans notre vieille capitale de nombreux
appartements qui s'apparente facilement
totti ainsi en va-t-il dans le quartier
du marais l'un des plus vieux quartiers
de paris
là entre saint germain l'auxerrois la
bastille dans des rues très étroites au
fond de court son soleil reliés entre
eux par des escaliers roulants et
nausées a beau s'en passe de logements
une pièce qu occupe bien souvent de
vieilles ces braves gens que rien sauf
la mort n'a rachat de la maison ils sont
là c'est pour venir en aide à ces
économiquement faibles que des jeunes
gens et jeunes filles sans distinction
de milieux se sont unis au sein d'un
groupe réparation logement leur but est
de lutter contre la misère de redonner
un sens au mot foyers en faisant de
l'habitation la plus simple à l'endroit
il fait bon vivre se reposer et se
souvenir
madame corps et vous avez 76 ans je
crois et depuis combien de temps me
dévoue cette maison se veut ça car vous
étiez autrefois marchand de
quatre-saisons
oui c'est toujours cela quatre saisons
depuis même après je m'appelais jeunesse
m
je vous rappelle avec ma mère je
poussais vêtir et vous avez perdu votre
mari il ya 25 ans et aux 27 ans 27 ans à
727 avait plus que 25 ans et vous vivez
seul depuis cette époque là depuis je
vis seul riz et depuis trois ans je
crois vous êtes malade et vous devez
rester couchés les filles 3 1 et oui et
matériellement comment vivez vous
combien de coups d'argent à dépenser par
la chanteuse 1000 francs par mois avec
la mairie
c'est la mairie qui vous donne une bonne
émission et oui et puis les oeuvres
sociales c'est ça c'est ça oui mais je
suis je suis contente de l'essentiel
pourquoi je me tiendrai à toi je suis
aidée j'ai des bons amis qu'est-ce qui
vous une petite amie madame barbara qui
est à côté vous savez qu'elle est très
gentil avec moi cette petite femme là
vous ne vous plaignez pas
je crois que vous aviez tout même un
petit sou et s'était brûlé refaire votre
maison c'est ça oui et alors combien
vous attendez seulement de 50 mille
francs pour faire la maison je crois que
vous allez recevoir justement les jeunes
gens du groupe réparation logement oui
oui et bien tu sais je voudrais qu'ils
sont très gentils et qu'est ce que vous
pensez alors de ces jeunes gens qui ne
vous ayez zador j'ai admis un site une
belle jeunesse savait qui j'espère
continuer enfin l'avenir pour soulager
leurs yeux les lieux elles ont besoin
d'avoir déjà naissent autour d'eux
parfois c'est bien contente de l'est
parce que ma nouvelle vie aux beaux
jours
quand vous êtes ici que vous auriez
peut-être aller vous promener je vous
remercie de tout mon coeur vous êtes
vraiment des des jeunes gens que landrin
que l'on doit les motions de madame
corée a bouleversé les jeunes mais elle
a aussi redoublé leur courage la
présentant conduit la vieille dame chez
une voisine nous peintre d'un jour
ouvrent leurs nouveaux chantiers et tous
oubliant qu'ils sont étudiants ouvriers
ou employés manieront le grattoir la
truelle le pinceau avec une dextérité de
professionnels
il est vrai que d'avoir le curage
ouvrage cela facilite grandement
[Musique]
voilà la thèse du minitel a joué le jeu
des mauves à sophie boyer débarrasser la
petite harlow et médicaments pour casser
les bouteilles vous passez du bo samedi
à réparer le jugement assez mature de
samedi après midi
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme travail je
suis dans un bureau je suis sténodactylo
comment il vaut mieux aux gros
préparation logement j'ai lu un article
dans un journal et j'ai trouvé ça très
bien mais pourquoi trouvez-vous ça très
bien le point de fût moralité je trouve
que c'est très bien dans le sens que
beaucoup de jeunes devraient faire ça
parce que au lieu de faire des loisirs
plus ou moins ça c'est quelque chose
d'utile en particulier pour les
personnes âgées qu'ils ont très peu de
ressources
est ce que le fait d'avoir rencontré ces
cas sociaux d'avoir pris connaissance
peut vous influencer dans votre vie dans
votre façon de penser de réfléchir
oh oui beaucoup parce que ça m'aide à
comprendre beaucoup mais certaines
personnes qui ont des difficultés que
lorsque vous en parler mais ne vous
n'êtes pas dans le dans le bain quoi
proprement dit vous vous ne pouvez pas
les comprendre de la même façon et puis
moi ça me sert à apprécier le confort
que je peux avoir chez moi alors que je
n'ai apprécié à sa juste valeur en femme
giroux oui vous êtes le fondateur du
groupe réparation logement je crois oui
enfin le fondateur avec quelques amis
obligé de monter ça les verrières en
octobre 1960 et pourquoi pourquoi parce
que nous sommes prêts nous étions un
certain nombre de jeunes et nous avions
envie de faire quelque chose dans le
domaine social enfin deux et pourquoi
avez vous choisi de justement de réparer
les taudis adore et bien parce que
actuellement en france comme dans
beaucoup de pays nous construisons
beaucoup de neuf et l'ancien personne
n'y touche le message délabre d'une
manière affreuse en particulier à paris
et là nous avons vu qu'il y avait
quelque chose à faire et comment
fonctionne alors votre groupe expliquez
moi que c'est par chaque nous avons des
équipes qui travaillent tous les quinze
jours chacun étant convoqué tous les
quinze jours et chacun des chantiers
donc à des gens qui travaillent le jeudi
le samedi et le dimanche après midi mais
chacun les travailleurs ne travaillent
qu'une fois tous les quinze jours dont
quatre à cinq heures après
quels sont les résultats leur obtenu est
bien le dernier nous avons fait 55
locaux cette année nous en ferons au
moins 120 150 michel vous vous êtes
apprentis soudeur pourquoi avez vous
jugé bon de venir à ce groupe parce que
j'avais du temps libre
premièrement vous auriez pu aller au
cinéma au faire du sport au théâtre j jv
actuellement
et j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu
dessous de te fais tu avais que qu'au
cinéma achetée c'est ça alors j'ai
cherché quelque chose à faire d'utile et
aussi pour bricoler un peu j'aime bien
bricoler puis aussi le travail d'équipé
m'a beaucoup intéressé beaucoup pourquoi
parce que par exemple à la tension on a
tendance à rester un peu sur soi même on
est égoïste en soi alors le travail
d'équipé mais le travail en commun c'est
plus intéressant est ici vous avez fait
connaissance avec des étudiants avec des
étudiantes et des secrétaires
oui comme je suis apprentie soudeur je
suis en rapport avec des gens qui ont
quand même un peu plus d'instructions
l'instruction que moi et j'apprends et
j'apprends leur manière la manière leur
manière de voir la vie pour vous de
cette expérience est avant tout à leur
enrichissement humain oui en
enrichissement humain d'ailleurs
réciproque parce que chacun donne un peu
nous nous donnons un peu notre joie
notre jeunesse au aux gens j'ai ou
familles nombreuses qui vivent entassés
dans des taudis mais réciproquement
ces gens nous donnent un peu de leur
leurs sentiments et de leur vie nous
enrichissent aussi voici remis à neuf
l'appartement de madame encore et
d'autres chantiers seront ouverts le
groupe opération logement vous attend
téléphoner à solférino où 83 38
[Musique]